is that all you've eaten is a pickle is
that it is the only thing you've eaten
is a pickle honey you've seen it on the
thing okay because when this outfit was
set up he's exactly right all I had was
a pet galani couple of them a couple of
couple is that like a is that a routine
or something what what the heck are you
usually I'm not always gonna bust out
the app y'all but this time I was like
you know what let's you know let's do
the Mark Mark Jacobs Runway look let's
just let's just throw it at y'all like
that gave it to us you gave it to us
tonight
um I want to also ask you about you took
a picture with your mom at your
billboard how cool was that man my mom
she's my family is my rock but my mom
she's always been my acting coach and
partner so for us to get to this moment
together it's us you know what I mean
how many times did you have to read the
script to understand what the hell was
going on I read a couple times and it
kept on changing yeah that's the thing
with Jordan is it's always evolving and
it's just about trust I trust him
endlessly as a creative
um and I think that's why it was such a
great experience for me okay in one
sentence tell me what this movie is
about one sentence one sentence this
movie is about family
really really come on now that that is a
lie that is okay just feel me if this
film is also about society and its
obsession with spectacles it's two
things it's hard to you you've made you
force me I understand but I'm like
family you can be one of the family
that's it
I've seen it well I've seen a lot of it
yeah I'm like yeah you have so you know
there's
there's a lot to it there's a lot to it
I also want to ask you if JLo got
married and you you were in Hustlers
together what'd you think I'm so happy
in power you know it's not easy for us
so I'm just happy for her yeah I feel
like you're giving us that Vibe with the
acting you're singing you're you're
hosting all those things that kind of
one of the people you emulate absolutely
Queen Latifah being the biggest
inspiration of mine I'll never forget
being here at this theater seeing
Barbershop 2 premiere and I filmed it
with her you know a year ago you know we
filmed it before we came to the premiere
and she remembered me I was only 10
years old I never forgot it yeah wow so
it's your mom and she's not here today
she is she's been all around she we took
a picture down there she probably you
know my mom likes to stay tucked in the
bag moving around yeah yeah
foreign